aujourd'hui roman bonjour madeleine
bonjour jacques vous allez bien mais
bien sages ont jugé sorti le tablier
parce qu'il ya de la farine de ça j'ai
pas envie de me salir
j'ai bien fait nous vous nous proposez
alors la galette des rois bien sûr vous
êtes la reine de la galette
je vais vous faire un petit fille aux
amandes entendu comme on fait alors nous
avons quatre jaunes de 80 g de beurre 2
100 g de sucre un peu d'extrait de
d'amandes de 200 grammes d'amandes et un
petit verre d'europe devant de suite
l'empaleur la pelote ses environs de 800
grammes d'accord oui on commence par
nous allons le faire la crème des tweeds
les 200 grammes d'amandes aux bruits et
200 g de sucre et le sucre semoule bien
sur wii ensuite les quatre jaunes de
tous ses biens est bonne on se
positionne s'est pas raté non peut-être
fait des remous la bannière ça dès le
début petite moue quand même or les 80 g
de beurre il y en a à peu près 80
grammes environ 95 de mes biens - oui
ah oui bien rôle important oui alors à
vous at-il verre de rhum
on peut mettre autre chose que du rhum
non c'est mieux de vous il peut dès lors
la danse country dément qu'est ce que
c'est alors de l'extrait d'amandes en
oui on en trouve dans le commerce où
l'on touche à cet effet mais en fait
c'est il en faut une petite cuillère oui
après à peine deux le titre et d'amandes
de noix your death d'accord rayonnement
et vous allez venu et ça pour faire les
aubades bien nommé jeudi à mêler pour
faire une crème assez épaisse d'accord
oui voilà zi muscles fait tourner bien
bon nous allons nous occuper de la pâte
oui je vais faire le fond du gâteau vous
allez peut-être m'approcher de la
découvrit la transmission de pensée
voilà où là qu'est ce que vous faites là
derrière mon dos qu'est ce que je peux
dire là c'est un mois vous avez peur non
pas vraiment alors vous avez donc le
fond de la galette oui et puis alors
reprenez la craie la crème aux amandes
tu es bien jaune est bien bonne je vous
avais je l'écouté ou la dégoûter oui je
sais fait goûter
il faut répartir je suppose
oui un peu marqué la cuisson terminera
le travail réparties en gros en fait
c'est une galette assez répandu qu'on
trouve assez facilement chez les
pâtissiers c'est la galette vraiment
traditionnelle et c'est assez facile à
formuler un simple on le voit oui alors
je vais couper le couvercle du dessus
oui un couvercle forcément alors vous
faites exactement la même taille exacte
l'oeil que la bonne petite roulette
parce que c'est plus décoratif je suis
pour rien n'est laissé au hasard chez
vous madeleine les petits détails voilà
qui font la différence qui termine de
bien alors je vais enduire le bord du
fond de la tarte avec un peu de blanc
qui servira à souder oui faut que ça que
le bien et de l'anhui bien alors où on
allait l'oublier l'a fait la fed va te
dis moi je regarde bien la société alors
oui c'est presque sentir les deux
troupes ok je sors d'arte un mélange ce
sera moins le roi ya plus de suspense le
couvert le corps voilà bien superposer
des deux bien égaliser ce que les deux
bords vous soudé légèrement avec les
doigts
tapotez oui oui et puis ensuite je
continue d'accord bon mais d'abord vous
dernier ses décorations vous allez aussi
sans doute doré une aurait la tâche
paris je vais rappeler les ingrédients
pour faire la crème est la galette des
rois il faut 600 g de pâte feuilletée
pour la crème 200 grammes d'amandes 200
g de sucre en poudre 80 g de beurre 4
jaunes 2 410 litres de rhum un jaune 2
pour dorer ce que vous êtes en train de
faire et le blanc pour souder voit
l'accusé fait une véritable merveille
manassé bourges a cassé pas mal oui mais
ça vaut
préchauffer le four au style 8 alors
220° oui pendant trois quarts d'heure
trois quarts des liens pendant ce temps
va rappeler l'adresse à nos
téléspectateurs c'est les grands
gourmands et faire 3 franche comté
avenue de la gare d'eau 25000 besançon
madeleine je crois qu'il faut la sortir
du fond parce qu'elle va bientôt dé voir
des elle a vraiment gonflé 1 ou la non
super enalotto revue pensé organiser ça
doit être là où il ya la feuille à mon
avis des eaux puis vous prenez même le
risque de la super suite par là alors
conseillé on va tichadou différé des
rois essayer de vous je vous serviez je
vous donnais vous savez moi je suis pour
l'égalité des chances
alors je vous sers donnez moi votre
assiette maintenant et bien jacques je
pense que j'ai une très très grande
chance ça aurait coûté 1 oui voilà pour
vous
voilà moi j'espère aussi avoir mes
chances 1 je crois que c'est pas mal
placé allez on y va préparer la grotte
batracienne orange mange que nos
gouvernants nazis
apparu la couronne pour moi un bon os
mais de toute façon jacques je pense que
vous êtes le roi
alors vous avez regardez bien jacques je
rêve ou quoi c'est vous qui avez la
feuille mais bien sûr des éléments n'y a
pas de justice a dit je vous fais rennes
et puis comme sans rancune j'espère vous
retrouver jeudi prochain à 12h28
vous retrouverez la reine indienne à
très bientôt merci
[Musique]